alors ils disent que c'est pour fournir
une assistance technique et sécuritaire
pour les trois centrales électriques qui
sont encore en fonctionnement et il y a
des problèmes liés à la campagne
d'attaque sur le système de génération
d'électricité en Ukraine menée par la
Russie si les centrales nucléaires n'ont
jamais été ciblés ils sont tout de même
affectés quand le réseau est endommagé
il y a eu en novembre deux fois je pense
la centrale de rive-né et la centrale de
melnitzky ont dû arrêter partiellement
leur production à certains temps pour
éviter des surcharges sur le réseau il y
a aussi la question de
l'approvisionnement en pièces détachées
et le maintien de ces centrales
nucléaires donc il y a des questions
liées à leur fonctionnement et puis il y
a aussi la question sécuritaire dans le
cas d'un éventuel attaque par la Russie
bien sûr personne ne veut que on est un
nouveau zapporisé avec une autre
centrale nucléaire en Ukraine soit
occupé par les forces russes l'armée
ukrainienne a mené des exercices autour
de la centrale de revenait dans le nord
du pays de la semaine dernière contre
l'éventualité d'une attaque possible
venant du côté de la Biélorussie la
frontière avec la Biélorussie n'est pas
très loin de cette centrale dans la
région de riveley bonjour Gulliver vous
l'évoquiez à l'instant précisément que
sait-on de la situation dans la centrale
de zaporigia qui est occupé depuis 10
mois maintenant par les forces russes
alors selon énerguatum l'agence d'État
ukrainien qui gère les centrales
nucléaires il y a un grand problème avec
la pression menée par la Russie sur les
travailleurs de la centrale ils accusent
la Russie d'avoir interdit l'accès même
à la centrale à 1500 travailleurs de la
centrale des aborigia pour essayer de
leur mettre la pression pour signer des
contrats avec rosatum l'agence russe qui
gère les centrales nucléaires les Russes
veulent que tout le monde passe côté
russe et prendre en son contrôle cette
centrale des abrisa et nerguatum résiste
absolument et dit que les personnes qui
signeraient des contrats avec rosatum
seront considérés comme des
collaborateurs et que leur contrats avec
l'Ukraine seront rompus et ils seront
peut-être poursuit une fois que
l'Ukraine aura regagné le contrôle sur
cette centrale alors guatum a une ligne
assez dure sur sur cette question et
puis Raphaël grossi le chef de la IEA
insiste que il y a quand même des
progrès dans ces tentatives de créer une
zone sécurisée autour de la centrale des
aporisa qui est toujours occupé par les
forces russes et les forces russes qui
ont stationné de l'équipement à
l'intérieur de cette centrale c'est un
endroit sûr en quelque sorte pour eux
parce qu'ils savent que les Ukrainiens
ne vont pas tirer directement sur la
centrale nucléaire il utilise donc comme
une plate Storm les ukrainiens et là
veulent essayer de mettre fin à cela
rafale grossit insiste que les
négociations se poursuivent il dit qu'il
a l'intention bientôt de se rendre en
Russie mais hésit de la veux même de
Raphaël aussi
les les progrès est très très long
beaucoup plus long qu'il le sous-trait
qu'il ne le souhaiterait
depuis Kiev pour France 24 merci
beaucoup Gulliver on continuera à
évoquer l'Ukraine avec